dans le sommaire au début du 100% gossip
on vous avait dit qu'on allait vous
révéler en exclusivité
c'est mon délire au point de vue féminin
parce que je dis à chaque fois que
personne n'ait mon délire six ans à
départ on dire ça n'est pas mon délire
et bien apparemment alors on est on est
pas chez vous et vous fait donc kelly
vdev ni mais apparemment vous êtes en
mesure de nous dire exactement enquête
après une longue enquête qui est mon
délire alors est ce qu'on a prévu on a
prévu un récapitulatif de alors on va
faire un recap et après moment je ne je
découvre cette émission s'il ya bien une
phrase qui est devenue culte dans tpm
paix au fil des années c'est bien
entendu ça n'est pas mon délire c'est
pas du tout mon délire grèce est pas mon
délire alors moi c'est pas mon délire
jolie ali perdu c'est pas mon délire
c'est pas mon délire la phrase préférée
de baba quand on parle du physique d'une
célébrité mais ça c'était avant 47
nouvelle année l'impossible est arrivé
baba enfin trouvé son délire il s'agit
de l'actrice margot robbie une
comédienne australienne de 28 ans qui a
notamment joué dans le loup de wall
street aux côtés de leonardo dicaprio
voici donc à quoi ressemble de délire de
cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
je vous dire elle est flouté j'aime pas
du tout ça s'est confirmé ce samedi
alors je confirme c'est ce que j'ai
c'est ce que j'ai dit à la prod et
j'aimerais savoir si vous pouvez
confirmer officiellement que c'est votre
dos le dernier le premier nommé juan de
toutes les autres j'aimerais que vous
confirmez vraiment que c'est elle vote
dos le number one de toutes les filles
de la planète comme ça alors combien
d'avions d'ali bongo
si c'est vrai alors qu'elle rajoute la
vérité le trad x
j'aime ce que j'aime bien d'enquêté oui
vous avez bien où il y aurait bien
d'autres tous mais non oui oui mais oui
c'est j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup et j'ai moi aussi
enquêter puisque j'ai fait en fait elle
est mariée show de galles est marié à 23
une photo de rêver d'elle avec son mec
regardez voilà un margot robbie est
mariée elle est mariée
on a une photo d'elle avec son mec donc
c'est ça qui est beau gosse ça qu'est ce
qu'il a dit ou fait ça n'est pas du tout
le même style que moi ce que vous avez
la prétention qu'on sait que c'est l'été
mispo nivelles serait intéressé par vous
alors vous vous avez la peau transférer
la prétention vous allez pouvoir me
parler comme ça mais c'était dans
l'émission
non mais vous avez raison je mets mon
vrai délire depuis des années c'est
britney spears non non et oui j'ai
toujours bien
on connaît alors savez ce que je vais
faire ce à l'insu vous dire déjà décidé
de la personne oui mais alors je vous
dirige pour l'instant je veux de
l'amitié voilà je suis son ami parce que
moi lâche elle aussi on voit là dedans
alors mais je suis pas là dedans non là
je ne sont pas là dedans mais je vais me
rendre je vous le dis s'il le faut
j'irai la chercher aux états unis les
gas actuellement à las vegas pas si
j'irai la chercher aux états unis et je
partirai aux états unis moi même pour
aller la rencontre est pour lui dire et
moi je filme tout non mais vous restez
où vous êtes
voilà non mais voila voila witness et
battre notre coeur mais n'en avaient pas
battre mon coeur s'est arrêté je suis
j'aime voilà je vais lui envoyer un
tweet tout de suite je vois ça répond je
lui ai envoyé des trucs sur un star on
va avoir un peu marre si airbus j'ai vu
qu'en ce moment elle s'occupait de son
papa y voilà c'est bien d'avoir
quelqu'un mais c'est vrai que ça va
swinger commentaires et voilà il demain
n'ayant pour l'honorer j'ai décidé de
refaire tous les clips de britney spears
[Applaudissements]
et je voulais je lui mettrais sur son
compte
après